alors ça n'est pas vrai si je puis
témoigner il se trouve qu'après
l'instauration du pass sanitaire pas du
pass vaccinale mais du passé sanitaire
j'ai beaucoup voyagé dans des pays
parfaitement démocratique je suis allé
en suisse je suis allé en allemagne vers
l'europe tous ces pays là en europe et
les voilà et dans tous ces pays ça
m'était jamais arrivé d'ailleurs
notamment en suisse c'est la première
fois qu'en suisse on me dit on va imiter
la france parce que vous mener une bonne
politique publique la suisse n'étant pas
un pays fasciste un certain pays ou s'il
parle il ya prés libéral non mais les
choses dans la région j'entends bien
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que si on
veut pousser l'analyse jusqu'au bout
étant donné quand même que dans les pays
dans les démocraties libérales disons
beaucoup de pays ont mis en place des
politiques qui a des détails près mais
ressembler à la politique de la france
et le passé sanitaire a été un
dispositif qui a été imité pour le coup
par beaucoup d'autres pays il faut aussi
assumer le fait si on est dans cette
analyse là bas il faut considérer que
c'est tout l'occident qui est en train
de tomber dans une partie de l'europe
qui est en train de tomber dans une
quasi dictature très honnêtement ça
défie un peu le bon sens vous pouvez
m'expliquer que la suisse et l'allemagne
l'italie basse ntem 2006 c'est la
première à la première question de jeu
frédéric taddeï genre mais bon ben on
veut jouer sur les mots mais frédéric
taddeï il a prononcé ce n'est pas dur
d'en vouloir l'âme l'écarté pas
soyez les régimes autoritaires recruter
l'ancien régime autoritaire bon alors
régime autoritaire dont il ya aussi un
régime autoritaire en allemagne aura
aussi en suisse y en a aussi en italie
on a eu aussi en galice surtout donc
ouais ouais non d'accord drian ce qui se
passe en voilà oui ben vous voyez mais
en fait non c'est pas une
frayeur n'est pas un argument si le bon
sens ça compte si si françois si si je
vous prends un excellent vous promets
que quand on va se promener dans ces
pays et quand on va se promener on
pourra prendre l'exemple des exemples
dans tes buts dans des pays dans
lesquels vraiment on peut pas dire ce
qu'on veut y compris dans les médias si
je peux vous dire que c'est quelque
chose qui compte
[Musique]